[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 18 décembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
il doit devenir un centre d'expertisé
technique mondial après un laboratoire
recherche et développement atos a
inauguré son datacenter un espace de
1300 mètres carrés aux clayes-sous-bois
le groupe de transformation digitale va
y héberger des technologies et serveurs
de pointe
quatre ong vont entamer une action en
justice contre l'état français lui
reprochent son action insuffisante conte
dans le réchauffement climatique un
document préalable a été adressé ce
lundi à emmanuel macron l un des
plaignants et greenpeace nous recevons
philippe d'orléans membres du groupe
local à versailles
enfin la suite de notre dossier de la
rédaction sur les cadeaux made in
yvelines elle est née à 18 au xviiie
siècle est la toile de jouy se décline
aujourd'hui en plusieurs produits
dérivés des motifs célèbre dans le monde
entier
reportage au sein de son musée dédié à
jouy en josas
et puis entretien à suivre dans ce
journal avec le maire de magny à les
hameaux bertrand lyon il réfléchit à la
création d'un téléphérique pour
désengorger le trafic dans sa commune il
avait installé un barrage durant six
jours devant le dépôt pétrolier avant
d'être délogés par les forces de l'ordre
jeudi dernier les gilet jaune sont de
retour à coignières et depuis hier
quelques personnes se mobilisent sur un
rond-point en bordure de nationale 10
non satisfait par les dernières annonces
du gouvernement est notamment
l'augmentation du smic via la prime
d'activité et en marge de ce mouvement d
gilet jaune un homme d'une trentaine
d'années est entre la vie et la mort
après une bagarre sur un barrage à ali
mais selon plusieurs sources une
personne extérieure au gilet jaune et
alcoolisée en seraient venus aux mains
avec la victime cette nuit aux alentours
de 3 heures du matin la chute aurait
occasionné des blessures cérébrales
importantes le blessé a été transféré en
urgence à l'hôpital de créteil dans le
val-de-marne une enquête a été ouverte
par le commissariat de mantes la jolie
le nouveau data center d'atos a été
inauguré ce matin sur le site des clés
sous voie une infrastructure pour
héberger et protéger des données
informatiques des clients du groupe
un outil stratégique dans l'activité
cybersécurité de cette entreprise
c'est à saint quentin en yvelines le
projet est notamment soutenu par le
département les détails de nicolas
landry des armoires prête à accueillir
des serveurs informatiques c'est un
datacenter la nouvelle infrastructure du
groupe atos dans son activité de cyber
sécurité
quelques semaines après avoir posé la
première pierre de son futur centre de
recherche et développement
alors vous êtes d'un module 2 seule
différence ce sont les couleurs le but
de tout ça c'est c'est se repérer dans
l'espace parle par le biais par le biais
des couleurs caractéristiques de ce data
center sa modularité aujourd'hui de
modules sont opérationnels soit 1300 m²
à terme 8 modules composeront
l'établissement sur un espace de 8000 m²
objectif renouveler les datacenter
existant sur les normes
environnementales et les capacités
informatiques les clés ce site c'est
vraiment un site qui est au coeur de
notre stratégie d'investissement pour
nos clients
externe à travers les data center mais
également pour nous mêmes pour pouvoir
avec nos ingénieurs de haute renommée
développer des ordinateurs de très
hautes performances quantique des
algorithmes quantique pour de bas et
également tous des produits de
cybersécurité le département des
yvelines a accompagné à atos hauteur de
5,5 millions d'euros à travers une aide
à l'innovation est l'acquisition
foncière d'un terrain pour le mettre à
disposition aider les entreprises à
créer de la richesse c'est la seule
façon de faire depuis 100 ans ensuite
avoir des politiques sociales
redistributive
les premiers clients d'atos installons
leurs serveurs en janvier 2019 des
partenaires du secteur de la santé de la
défense ou encore de la distribution un
invité ma a rejoint en plateau philippe
d'orléans bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
membre du groupe local de greenpeace
aversa et greenwheels et trois autres
ong veulent attaquer l'état en justice
pour son action insuffisante contre le
réchauffement climatique un document
préalable a été transmis ce lundi l'état
a deux mois pour y répondre
pourquoi lancer cette action alors on
cite juste les quatre ong oxfam la fnh
l'association notre affaire à tous et
donc greenpeace parle de carence fautive
de l'état en matière de réchauffement
climatique
alors effectivement la coque 24 vient de
se terminer et une fois de plus
l'ensemble des associations qui
travaillent sur le réchauffement
climatique ont été extrêmement déçus par
les résultats et nous constatons en
particulier en france que l'état ne
tient pas ses engagements
alors nous avons vous le savez par
différentes actions auprès des instances
dirigeantes auprès des entreprises
auprès de la sensibilisation du public
essayer de deux d'actionner tous les
leviers que nous pouvions axonais mais
malheureusement les résultats sont
encore insuffisants et une action
complémentaire était jugé possible en
menant cette action en justice l'avait
dit on est à quelques jours juste après
la fin de cette coque 24 qui se
déroulait à katowice en pologne lors de
ces discussions politiques on parle de
limiter le réchauffement climatique à 2
degrés les experts du giec ont
me voilà on dit récemment que ce
réchauffement climatique il fallait le
limiter à 1,5 degré il ya vraiment un
décalage entre l'urgence climatique et
les décisions politiques les discussions
politiques alors en tout cas il y à un
décalage de façon très précise
en france les résultats internationaux
ne sont pas bons mais en france on
constate un décalage par exemple la
france s'était engagée à réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et on
constate en 2016 2017 et malheureusement
2018 que la france va augmenter ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
on n'est pas du tout sur la bonne
trajectoire et c'est une des demandes
que les quatre associations dont
greenpeace fait lors de ce recours pour
faire en sorte que l'état revienne sur
la bonne trajectoire de voix pour vous
répondre
à quoi doit répondre clairement les
alors sur ces deux mois a plusieurs
points dont principalement la réduction
puisqu'on constate ceci est mesurée
évidemment par des organismes
internationaux dont le chèque on
constate que la france augmente ses
émissions alors que le giec le préconise
45% de réduction de gaz à effet à serre
exactement et en particulier en france
nous avons un problème concernant les
énergies renouvelables la france s'était
engagée à faire en sorte qu'en 2020 nous
ayons 23% d'énergies renouvelables
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 16 % c'est
en deux ans doit passer de 16 à 23 %
alors que la trajectoire que l'état
français s'était fixé était à ce jour 2
19% à leurs côtés mais la crise et gilet
jaune l'état russe a reculé finalement
sur la hausse sur la taxe des carburants
ça c'est un mauvais signal aussi envoyé
selon vous alors c'est sûr que c'est un
mauvais signal
il est il est évident que les mesures
concernant l'augmentation
dugain du gasoil concert pour pour qui
était à l'origine de la crise du lait
des jv les jaunes a été une mesure qui
était très maladroite car beaucoup de
gilet jaune soutiennent le fait qu' il
fallait faire quelque chose contre le
réchauffement climatique mais de façon
juste de façon redistributive et et non
de façon abrupte comme cela l'a été fait
on ne peut pas à gagner la lutte sur le
contre le réchauffement climatique
si on crée des injustices car notamment
les personnes les plus défavorisées sont
les premières victimes du réchauffement
climatique donc il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre le social et
l'environnement et donc si vous n'avez
pas obtenu satisfaction dans ces deux
mois que vous voulez c'est à l'état il y
aura une action en justice qui sera
extrait entamée alors c'est une
procédure qui est longue puisque
effectivement on fait une demande
préalable indemnitaire au premier
ministre et c'est au premier ministre et
à une dizaine de ministres du
gouvernement sur les mesures qu'il
compte prendre ou qu'il a prises déjà
pour remédier à cette ce réchauffement
climatique
si ces réponses ne nous satisfont pas eh
bien nous allons effectivement aller
devant le tribunal administratif
et si le tribunal administratif à une
réponse qui ne nous satisfait pas nous
allons pouvoir aller en appel dont vous
voyez que c'est une procédure de longue
haleine alors juste pour terminer cet
entretien il nous reste un tout petit
peu plus d'une minute sur les actions
locales de greenpeace à versailles il
notamment deux grandes dernière
opération la marche contre le climat qui
a été organisée partout en france et
aussi à versailles le 8 décembre est
aussi une action contre un géant un
géant du biscuit un géant de
l'agroalimentaire oui toutes les
campagnes de greenpeace sont liés en
fait on réchauffement climatique car la
déforestation
par définition un impact direct sur le
climat et nous avons participé nous
avons organisé à un étiquetage sur une
une marque de biscuits oreo qui
s'approvisionnait notamment en huile de
palme liées à la déforestation n'y aura
pas vraiment de l'huile de palme non
durables et son fournisseur qui était et
wilmar a été visé directement qui nous
avons une bonne nouvelle puisque wilmart
s'est engagé dorénavant à approvisionner
oreo en huile de palme durable alors
tout ceci ne sont que des engagements
cela reste à vérifier on voit que tous
les engagements ne sont pas toutes les
actions portent leurs fruits tout les
toute l'offre les informations toute
l'actualité du groupe lequel a retrouvé
sur le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci fille d'orléans d'avant
crise y avait ou membres de greenpeace à
versailles et un autre entretien à
retrouver tout de suite dans ce journal
enregistré tout à l'heure avec le maire
de magny les hameaux bertrand au lion un
téléphérique pour répondre au problème
des bouchons c'est une solution avancée
par vous bertrand guillon bonsoir
bonsoir il est le maire de magny les
hameaux est également vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement durable et de la ruralité
et vous réfléchissez à cette solution
depuis deux ans une idée de création
d'un téléphérique entre la gare rer b de
saint rémy les chevreuse et la future
gare saint quentin est à guyancourt de
la ligne 18
un projet qui pourrait passer par votre
commune magny les hameaux pour répondre
je disais une problématique celle de la
circulation c'est une vraie inquiétude
dans votre commune ce problème de la
circulation c'est plus qu'une inquiétude
se noue vraie problématique
je dis souvent magny les hameaux comme
voisin par exemple soit un petit peu la
zone tampon entre la partie d'emploi qui
est saint quentin en yvelines où le nord
de notre territoire
et puis la partie d'habitat qui est
plutôt le sud yvelines
voire même plus loin avec un tissu rural
qui a pas forcément de réponses en
termes de transports en commun en tout
cas en termes d'alternatives aux
véhicules particuliers et on le constate
à chaque heure de pointe dans un sens et
puis après dans l'autre un certain
nombre de bouchons
pour passer les vallées puisque magny
les hameaux et tout simplement entouré
de vallées on ne supprimera pas là les
chevreuse le plateau de saclay
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ya plein de
véhicules qui transitent par armani il y
avait surtout une voirie qui est de
toute façon pas adéquate même par
rapport par rapport au passage des
véhicules
et forcément trop de véhicules
particuliers qui transitent par ce biais
là des réponses qu'on a su apporter au
fur et à mesure des années en termes de
transports en commun en termes de en
terme de deux bus mais qui ne répondent
que de manière très local et aujourd'hui
on voit bien ce sont des gens qui
viennent de plus en plus loin pour
travailler sur notre territoire a
expliqué nous un petit peu en détail
votre idée relier ces deux gares saint
quentin en yvelines 50 un ace sur la
ligne 10 800 et 1000 et creuse pour le
rer b pourquoi c'est un projet qui
pourrait être intéressant en tout cas
pourquoi vous verrez ces réflexions
qu'on a eu dans le cadre notamment du
budget collaboratif qui est une une
façon participative de travailler sur le
budget chaque année et il ya deux ans
donc on l'a mis en place et dans les
discussions avec les habitants qui
étaient présents on s'est dit bon
comment réussir à passer les vallées
pour pouvoir faciliter la mobilité
depuis magny les hameaux jusque sur le
nord du territoire passé à l'intérieur
des vallées en rajoutant des routes
c'est pas possible on arrose naturels
forêts domaniales hors de question faire
un viaduc ça coûte horriblement cher et
ça détruirait aussi l'ensemble des
paysages un tunnel encore moins possible
et on s'est dit après tout il faut
réussir à passer par dessus et la
meilleure des façons de passer par
dessus une vallée de manière la moins
visible possible pour pour
l'environnement c'est peut-être un
transport par câble
un transport par cars veut pas forcément
dire de passer au dessus de tout
aujourd'hui il ya certaines solutions
innovantes qui sont plutôt quasiment au
sol même voilà c'est un transport par
câble en question du lizon sonore tout
simplement et 10 et qui séduit le
transport par câble il ya des projets
similaires notamment de vélizy pour
rejoindre le pont de sèvres sais pas où
ils vont qui est un projet un petit peu
différent mais pour relier la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines à celle de
plaisir par cas voilà les c'est surtout
que pendant très longtemps en france on
a considéré ces transports par câbles
spécifiques à la montagne voilà on va
faire du ski on un transport par câble
mais on n'imagine pas ailleurs c'est une
solution qui qui peut être intéressante
je ne dis pas en fait aujourd'hui que
c'est la solution simplement depuis deux
ans je demande aux collectivités
compétentes dans ce domaine et donc à la
région puisque c'est l'organisateur des
transports en ile-de-france d'étudier
cette possibilité d'étudier en termes
juridiques d'abord pour savoir si en
fonction de l'ensemble des protections
de notre territoire c'est faisable de
l'étudier aussi en termes techniques de
savoir un passage de vale en termes de
pylônes à établir est-ce que c'est
faisable
et puis après surtout en termes de flux
est ce que ce type de transport pour
répondre au flux que nous avons sur
l'axé sud nord sur notre territoire
et puis c'est une solution qui n'est pas
une seule solution ou qui serait la
solution miracle moi je ne suis pas dans
le syndrome de la ligne 18 comme
beaucoup de mes collègues qui disent que
c'est la solution miracle pour tous en
fait c'est peut-être comme solution je
ne sais pas ça doit être vu aussi
souvent on me dit ben transport par
câble c'est peut-être le moins coûteux
je ne sais pas je veux que ça soit
étudiée c'est un préalable à tout après
c'est une solution
une autre qui doit pouvoir s'accompagner
d'autres éléments qui doit pouvoir
s'accompagner de swing relais un peu
plus loin de prolongation du rer c en
fait tout ce qu'on demande de rénovation
du rer b tout ce qu'on demande depuis 20
30 40 ans sur le territoire mais qui n'a
jamais avancé
et cette réflexion vous avez entamé il
ya deux ans elle en est où est ce que
vous avez écrit par exemple à la région
à ile-de-france mobilité sur sur le
sujet alors j'ai invité je veux dire la
terre entière de l'état jusqu' aux
collectivités les plus proches
je les avais invité en début d'année à
ce que j'avais appelé une conférence
territoriale des mobilités pour qu'on
puisse enfin sortir justement de la
discussion qu'on a depuis quelques
années qui se résume uniquement à la
lime 18,2 de voir plus large et de voir
justement toutes les solutions qui avait
envisagé depuis 10 20 30 ans qui n'ont
jamais été mises en place pour des
questions peut-être de beck qui a la
compétence sur bois qui finance quoi et
qui ont été retardées d'année en année
nous on le voit directement sur notre
territoire et que le transport en commun
en site propre qui devait relier ou qui
devrait relier saint quentin en yvelines
à massy qui s'est jamais mis en place
jusqu'à maintenant peut-être un jour
en tout cas il faut qu'on puisse avoir
aujourd'hui savoir qui fait quoi sur des
solutions qui déjà sont envisagés depuis
des années techniquement qui intervient
et finance et financièrement qui
intervient et dans quel calendrier
c'était là dessus que j'avais interrogé
tout le monde j'ai eu des réponses très
polis mais des noms au début de l'année
j'ai relancé sa en septembre suite à des
discussions qu'ont avec voisins le
bretonneux par rapport à un projet de
rocade où on s'y est pris un petit peu
le bec long on a beaucoup discuté avec
ma collègue alexandra rosetti sur ce
sujet et on a convenu de relancer la
machine mais dessus donc en octobre
renouveau de nouveau un courrier là
bizarrement ça change un petit peu
donc affaire à suivre mais j'espère
surtout qu'on puisse se mettre vraiment
en commun pour pouvoir réfléchir à des
solutions plus durables alternatif à
l'évacuer au véhicule particulier sur
nos territoires
merci bertrand au lion d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et je rappelle que vous
êtes le maire de magny les hameaux
[Musique]
et j - 7 avant noël toute cette semaine
nous vous donnons des idées de cadeaux
made in heaven qui a dit que la toile de
jouy était ringarde de nombreux
créateurs s'inspirent de cette cotonnade
inventé est produite à jouy en josas
aujourd'hui de nombreux produits sont
déclinés reportage au musée de la toile
de jouy et dans sa boutique ou 800
références sont vendues chaque année les
images de mélanie poké elle est la
création d'un homme oberkampf qui la
fabrique à partir de 10 760 à jouy en
josas la toile de jouy est apprécié à
l'époque pour sa grande qualité et la
précision de ses dessins le tissu est
très vite prisé par la bourgeoisie et la
noblesse française
le succès de la toile de jouy tient à la
proximité de jouy en josas avec le
château de versailles
christophe depover qu en fait été un
visionnaire tendant
les motifs et d'un point de vue créatif
que dans sa gestion industrielle de la
manufacture la cour qui étaient
effectivement à proximité raffolez
da sa production si aujourd'hui
l'indienne ne se fabriquent plus dans sa
ville d'origine ces motifs célèbre se
décline en de nombreux produits dérivés
au sein du musée de la toile de jouy une
boutique où l'on peut trouver chaussures
bijoux trousse ou encore de la vaisselle
les plateaux qui ont été fait cette
année dans un motif bengale et ce choix
était fait surtout pour les couleurs que
manuel canovas utilise donc dans un ton
dans des tons aubergines
nous avons aussi une autre collection
des tôles qui a été fait dans un motif
dont qui a été pris dans les fonds
muséal dans le motif de l'offrande à
l'amour donc nous avons quatre coloris
qui ont été fait cette année donc dans
ce rouge basque arrose poupe et un vert
de gris
à chaque saison sa collection pour
l'automne hiver le produit phare cette
année c'est une marinière créé en
partenariat avec la marque armor lux un
vêtement fabriqué à l'occasion de
l'exposition sur le peintre franco
japonais fuji tas qui se tient en ce
moment au musée de la toile de jouy
nous avons repris donc le motif
de l'armée mais que vous jugez pas
utiliser énormément dans ses oeuvres et
nous avons décidé de reprendre le bateau
donc un petit sinagot qui a été mise
dans les
dans les coudes hier
des mariniers deux marques sont
disponibles dans la boutique collection
et création du musée de la toile de jouy
et pour panser ses produits
l'inspiration ne manquent pas au musée
qui possède un fonds de 10000 pièces de
toile de jouy de beignets effectivement
dans tous ces dessins je m'en lasse pas
je trouve toujours des choses nouvelles
c'est d'une richesse incroyable bon moi
ce que j'aime aussi beaucoup faire c'est
justement retravaillé tous les motifs
que nous avons mis dans les réserves
notamment les empreintes aussi des
choses fabuleuses
donc ça je décline avec sobre énormément
de papeterie aussi dans la boutique il y
en a pour tous les goûts et pour toutes
les bourses conti de 3 à 200 euros pour
ses produits au motif de la toile venue
de jouy en josas
[Musique]
elle m'a rejoint en plateau mélanie
poquet bonsoir alors plus que quelques
jours à patienter avant les vacances de
cette fin d'année et 2018 c'est encore
l'occasion d'aller voir des spectacles
ou expositions mélanie vous avez
sélectionné vous en avez sélectionné
quelques-uns pour grégory je vous
propose de commencer avec de la danse
est une oeuvre d'anne teresa de
keersmaeker
figure majeure de la danse contemporaine
en la chorégraphe belge est au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur la
scène nationale achterland une oeuvre
charnière créée en 1990 pour huit
danseurs lorsqu'ils ont fait une vraie
charnière c'est que anne teresa de
keersmaeker chorégraphie à l'époque
principalement pour des femmes ici à mes
femmes évoluent ensemble
autre force de la pièce les musiciens
jouent en live pour accompagner au plus
près les mouvements les intentions des
danseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre rendez vous un moment de cirque
avec la compagnie du fil à retordre qui
se bat pour continuer à jouer dit eh oui
dans un cirque un petit peu à la dérive
à la recherche tous les stratagèmes
possibles pour faire entrer de l'argent
dans les caisses ces spécimens sont
quatre aristide qui est le monsieur
loyal bérengère josy et postroff alors
c'est un spectacle drôle à voir dès
l'âge de 3 ans épouse en avant bourse
merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
merci mélanie pour ces rendez-vous alors
avant de nous quitter où il est tout de
même nous donner un autre coup de coeur
il s'agit d'une exposition et une
exposition à but caritatif elle se
déroule jusqu'à ce vendredi le 21
décembre au centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux alors une
quarantaine de tableaux d'artistes
locaux pour la plupart sont exposés et
proposés à la vente ils ont été
collectées par une association vie
chinoise espoir à tchernobyl les fonds
récoltés aideront notamment pauline à
une jeune fille nés avec des
malformations belle cause merci alors
votre dernier c'est une culture et à
retrouver tout à l'heure le dernier set
une culture de l'année n'a pas de la
saison on vous retrouvera dès janvier
c'est à retrouver après ce journal en
attendant les élèves de la compagnie
déclic théâtre se sont donné rendez vous
samedi dernier à l'école de musique et
de danse de tra total déclic total
déclic une après midi dédié au match
d'improvisation théâtrale trois
catégories étaient représentées que
nicolas dandrieux a suivi le commentaire
d'origne ans
[Applaudissements]
ils ont entre 8 et 11 ans et viennent de
s'affronter lors de matchs
d'improvisation théâtrale deux fois par
an la compagnie trappistes déclic
théâtre organise ces réunions pourront
mettre en avant la jeune génération y en
a qui nous ont rejoints cette année qui
n'ont jamais fait de mal l'impro donc
les premières patinoire aussi que les
parents se rendent compte du travail qui
est effectué et que leurs enfants sont
talentueux et content d'être là donc
donc voilà c'est la petite réunion du
samedi concentration pendant le briefing
suivi de quelques exercices
d'articulation et de conseils pour les
plus stressés si la rdc comme papa il a
d'autres trucs qu'il a le trac elle est
bien failli être la première des bureaux
c'est le trac et lecture entre la
première fois après ça passe après
quelques échauffements c'est parti pour
le lancement des improvisations
[Musique]
c'est super bien passé c'est marrant on
a rigolé c'était bien au début on était
stressés mais après être entré dans la
patinoire tout à coup des on est sur la
patinoire pour cent on voit public donc
on est un peu stressé mais qu'après
qu'on se laisse aller sa valeur première
patinoire donc leur premier match
d'impro et sont très bien débrouillés
ils ont bien mis ils ont bien appliqué
ce qu'ils ont appris en cours après
voilà il ya toujours des choses à faire
progresser notamment par les plus forts
s'écouter mais voilà donc ça vient ça
reste à venir avec le temps mais c'est
une très bonne première
cet après midi dédié à l'improvisation
s'est poursuivie avec les matchs des
cadets et des juniors et c'est la fin de
ce journal vous retrouvez demain un
reportage qui était prévu ce soir sur
les archers du en cours qui organisaient
leur dernier tournoi annuel c'était ce
week end belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]